good evening the trend of street racing
can be heard all across the valley and
tonight another neighborhood in north
las vegas say they have had enough
thanks for joining us i'm denise valdez
and i'm brian loftis neighbors are
complaining about loud noise smoke in
the air and the danger those drivers are
to the community madison kimbrough live
near one area with more on what's
happening
i want you guys to take a look at the
road behind me i'm going to step out of
the way it's a long while till you reach
a stop sign and neighbors say the cars
racing up and down these streets have no
regard for the people in the
neighborhood and it's only a matter of
time before the drivers crash into
someone
[Music]
we've been having a lot of racing around
the neighborhood
people not stopping for the stop signs
and just basically spinning donuts in
the middle of the road on bruce tammy
royabaugh has lived in her house for
five years and says street racing has
always been a problem in her
neighborhood in north las vegas but as
of late it has gotten bad to the point
where she hears it not once but several
times a day as she works from home it
could be in the middle of the day when
the kids are coming home from school it
happens right in the middle between the
houses
or it can also be
late at night so it's just very random
when it happens but it's more than just
the loud noises it takes a lot to create
tire marks like these so i see a whole
bunch of smoke in the air it looks like
almost a fire
so i thought it was maybe a car on fire
or something but no i just walk outside
and they're doing donuts right here it's
just kind of scary because
you're hearing this type of stuff and
you don't really know what's going on so
you can't really you don't really feel
peaceful sleeping at night according to
neighbors several have been in touch
with the north las vegas pd and the
authorities say they will handle it
somebody is going to come around that
corner one of these days and not know
that the kid is spending donuts in the
middle of the road and someone is going
to eventually get killed